he came to give a lecture about freedom
of expression in the united states but
left on a stretcher headed to hospital
and emergency surgery
police say the celebrated author salman
rushdie was stabbed in the neck and the
abdomen
witnesses say it happened quickly he had
just walked onto the stage was still
being introduced less than a minute
before the event began after the event
began
and a man rushed from this audience up
onto the stage
and started punching or stabbing it
wasn't quite clear but there was clearly
some sort of blood or red liquid
going in many directions a collective
sigh of shock from the audience we have
a paramedic here rusty's alleged
assailant was quickly taken into police
custody and the attack decried by local
leaders we are undeterred in our
commitment to make sure
that we call it out we condemn what
happened we condemn all violence
and we want people to feel that freedom
to
speak and to write
truths
salman rushdie was forced into hiding in
1989 after his book the satanic verses
was denounced by the iranian leader
ayatollah ruhalah khomeini
many considered the book blasphemous in
its portrayal of the prophet muhammad
but even before khomeini's ruling it had
sparked protests and been banned in
several countries
a bounty of three million dollars was
offered to anyone that would kill the
british author
but even as rushdie was being burned in
effigy he was celebrated in the west and
later knighted by great britain many in
the muslim world did not believe that it
amounted to an act of blasphemy nor
indeed did many in the muslim world
believe that he deserved to die for it
but those voices of moderation and
indeed
those voices of a more more secular
dispensation were crushed
more recently russia could often be seen
at public events
the lecture was expected to focus on the
role of the united states as a home for
free expression and an asylum for
writers and other artists in exile
kristin salumi al jazeera new york